flying doesn't affect your body
it does
autopilot flies the plane for you
no it does not it is more dangerous to
fly during the night than the day
now it's the same hi my name is captain
zoya and i'm a commander on the boeing
triple sevens with indian flag carrier
air india and i have been doing this for
the last well 17 years i'm raj lakshmi
ishwar people call me raji my first
officer on boeing triple seven with our
national carrier air india and today we
are going to be debunking myths about
flying bad turbulence can crash a plane
not true so chances are the turbulence
that you're going to face on your flight
is not going to crash your airplane a
lot of times how the turbulence happens
is there is a wind shift the change of
wind direction and or speed
that's what destabilizes the airflow
which is what causes turbulence we are
well prepared to avoid these
circumstances first of all we on ground
go through all the papers and the
research required to avoid them we have
the weather reported to us we have
radars on board which kind of depicts on
our screen that there is turbulence this
way and you may get it and even if we do
enter some turbulence we can always slow
the aircraft down these aircrafts are
structurally built to withstand such
turbulence so more often than not the
turbulence that you encounter is
probably just mild and something that
you're going to sail through in just a
few minutes so long as you stay seated
put your seat belts on stay calm
breathe in breathe out you'll be fine
lightning can bring down a plane no
i know it sounds scary right lightning
there are occasions that there could be
lightning around but the aircrafts that
we fly these days are structurally built
to handle these lightnings and we have
static discharges and various other
things that just discharges any
lightning that could possibly strike an
aircraft so that right there is a meth
cabin air will make you sick
does it cabin air will not make you sick
we have air purification through hepa
filters on board that air is
continuously recirculated which is mixed
with the outside fresh air it's going
through various filter various status
before it reaches you so at any point in
time you're breathing in fresh combined
air probably one of the other thing that
you're confusing is motion sickness or
altitude sickness but it's not the
cabinet so watch your food intake please
be hydrated and you will be fit as a
fiddle flying doesn't affect your body
it does
have you gone on these flights and then
you come land and then you're like so
exhausted and dehydrated i wonder all
the time
all the time
so yes flight does affect your body
let's start with the dehydration bit
right your aircraft there is pressurized
and it is pressurized to an altitude
between 5000 to 9000 feet it's not
natural to be at such an elevation for a
human body and then secondly the
aircrafts do feel pretty dry in the air
what you're dealing with is very very
dehydrated air the humidity levels of
the air is extremely low and also you
know when you're in the airplane taking
those 16-hour long flights chances are
you're gonna have coffee and alcohol
perhaps which is going to dehydrate you
further secondly you're also sitting
down for a long period of time and you
have limited space and that kind of
reduces the airflow in your body which
is why we're always encouraged on the
flights to move around every now and
then to increase the blood flow in your
body the best thing you can do is
hydrate yourself and maybe get up and
stretch a little bit your body will
definitely re-adjust once we land so
don't worry about it it is more
dangerous to fly during the night than
the day
no it's the same the only difference is
that during the day we have some visual
references which probably makes us feel
slightly more comfortable but with the
instruments that we fly day or night
makes no difference typically as pilots
we fly instrument right rules which
means that we have predefined routes so
we don't require any visual references
in the night we have the route data
which we put into the flight management
system and pretty much guide the
aircraft through the route we ensure
that whether it's day or whether it is
night those air outs are followed to the
t flying is more dangerous than driving
no
no no no no no is by far one of the most
safest means of travel if you ask me
we follow high standards of safety
everything from the get-go the aircraft
is maintained with safety in mind pilots
are trained with safety in mind air
routes are planned with safety in mind
imagine a million miles of air travel
and not a single accident now imagine a
million miles on the road do you think
it'd go on without an accident no
no no right i guess there must be
something right yeah
so flying is i think
way safer than something like crossing
the road it's super super safe
everything is based on passenger safety
that is a priority autopilot flies the
plane for you
no it does not there are so many times
i'm with friends and they're like you
have an autopilot right it pretty much
does your job you're pretty much sitting
back and relaxing while your autopilot
is doing your job we control the
autopilot we tell the autopilot what to
do we give all the commands for it what
altitude to fly what airspeed to fly
what route to fly we are right there
monitoring every single thing and the
purpose of the autopilot is to reduce
the workload of a pilot so the pilot can
think on
the bigger picture thinking about what
next can we do to make the flight better
in every single way pilots must have
perfect vision
no perfect corrected vision that's
something we need you must see plenty of
pilots with glasses on right even if you
have spectacles on as long as it is 20
20 vision it's all right i have six by
six she has six by six which is 20 by 20
over here over here but by far
so long as you have corrected vision um
well you can totally fly yes pilots all
have parachutes under their seats
no we don't only the uh fighter
airplanes yes yeah like not the
commercial ones what we have is life
vests which is same as every other
passenger on board pile of sleeve for
most of the flight
yeah we don't have that choice
like really we don't i mean except if
it's like a long-haul flight and you
have multiple crew when the flights are
very very long
that's when you are given your
designated dress and which you must rest
which is what exactly we did yesterday
from delhi to
new york we flew almost
16 hours yeah on the other side of the
world when you're doing such long
flights uh you do have multiple set of
crew two captains to first offices what
normally happens is there is one set of
crew that sits on the control in the
cockpit while the other two goes into
the bunk rests up so that when the first
set of crew is tired we come and replace
them and we sit while they go sleep
because it is humanly not possible to be
attentive for 16 17 hours straight
staying awake through a flight will cure
jet lag
no
no no it does not in fact it'll worsen
what i have discovered in my
career is there is no cure for jetlag
there is no shortcut for jet lag you
know i've been asked this question so
many times oh you must be a pro at
handling jet lag no you never pick up a
pro and handling jet lag i wish i did
you can minimize it by
resting you can minimize it by staying
fit hydrating yourself and the best
thing to do is when you land back just
try to adjust as much as you can to the
local time try to eat at their times
sleep at the times that's the best you
can do but you have to go through the
process sorry yeah all of us do after
every flight it's just there and there
is no escape i wish there was a magic
potion though yeah i'll be the first
customer so for people who are boarding
an aircraft please don't be afraid to
fly you are in hands of very
well-trained crew
pilots and the aircrafts are built to
handle the stress so don't be afraid